[Music]
hi everyone thanks for coming today so I
want to talk to you about something that
sounds like science fiction but very
much is reality an AI coding agent that
helped build itself my name is Colin I'm
an AI researcher at augment code a
company building AI power Dev tools for
software engineering orgs and I want to
share with you a little bit about my our
journey working on AI coding
agents so zooming out AI Dev tools is a
fast changing space everyone remembers
in 2023 we're all talking about
autocomplete models GitHub co-pilot
being the one that probably really comes
to mind in 2024 chat models really
started to penetrate software
engineering Orcs
in 2025 though we think AI agents are
going to dominate the conversation about
how software engineering is
changing so naturally a few months ago
we started building our own agent at
augment I want to show you a sneak peek
of what we built and share some
hard-learned lessons about how this Tech
works and I just want to you know
reiterate I've been really amazed to see
the extent to which this agent has
helped build itself uh I'll not a kind
of fun statistic so we have about 20,000
thousand lines of codee in our uh agent
code base and over 90% of that was
written by our agent with with human
supervision so what does it mean for the
agent to write itself implementing core
features so one of the first things we
had we had to add was third-party
integration so our agent you know if
it's going to work like a software
engineer it needs to interact with slack
linear jira notion search Google um muck
around in your code base and so we
wanted to have the agent help us build
these
features uh we had it we found after we
added the first few ourselves when we
add asked it to you know gave it an
instruction like add a Google search
integration it was able to go look in
our code base for the right file to add
it in uh figure out the right interface
to use and go add it uh one kind of fun
an anecdote is when we were adding the
linear integration uh it didn't know the
linear API docs the foundation model
we're using uh didn't have those
memorized and so it used the Google
search integration which it had written
previously to go look up the linear API
docs and then was able to add
that uh we used it to write tests so we
found if we asked it something like add
unit tests for the Google search
integration it was able to go add those
uh in order to do this we just had to
give it some basic Process Management
tools things like running a subprocess
interacting with it uh not hanging if
there's an infinite Loop in some test it
wrote and and reading
output um I think this is super
interesting so everyone's seen the
Twitter demos of these agents writing
features and writing tests but I haven't
yet seen a compelling example of them
performing some kind of
optimization well over the course of our
project we KN noticed the agent was
pretty slow and we weren't sure why so
we asked it to profile itself and what
it ended up doing using all these tools
we'd given it was add some print
statements to its own code base run
essentially sub copies of itself looked
through these print statements and it
figured out there was a part of our code
base where we were loading up all the
files in the users's
repository uh synchronously and hashing
them synchronously and then it added a
process pool for these to speed it up
and a stress test to confirm it was all
working and by the end of this we
reached about 20,000 lines of code and
again over 90% of that was written by
the agent with with our help in
supervision so let's walk through a
quick example
a couple quick examples to see how the
agent works I focus on simple examples
where it's reliable so you can uh follow
along
easily so here I asked the agent are you
able to search Google and then it notes
that it found a tool called Google
search for those who aren't familiar
with the notion of tools I'm sure most
of you are but I'll just kind of quickly
reiterate the idea is we have this kind
of Master Level agent that's doing all
the planning and it has access to
certain tools that it can use to
interact with it its environment with
that's the third party Integrations I
talked about like Google or it's editing
a file in the user's repository and then
it wants to confirm this that this
Google Search tool is working so it
sends a query to it of tests and the
agent uh uh responds to us yes I can
search Google and I see the first 10
results let's try something a little bit
more complicated I ask it instrument
agent's Google Search tool with logs and
then generate an example then it uses
our retrieval tool which is you know
allows to search uh the local codebase
and it's looking for a file related to
Google search Integrations it finds this
file deep in our directory hierarchy at
Services integration thirdparty gooogle
search to.py and then it calls its file
editing tool to quickly and performant
edit that file to add those print
statements uh this is a continuation of
the last example so it added those print
statements and now it wants to run a a
sub copy of itself so it can look at the
output of those print statements uh
because we asked it for example logs uh
but in doing so it finds that we don't
have Google uh credentials authorized so
it uses its clarify tool to ask for
clarification from the user it asks I
don't see Google credentials would you
like me to one add stub for Google API
or to guide you through setting up
credentials I note that the credentials
are actually stored in augment gooogle
api. Json it had just missed this and
then here's a a really cool extra
feature we have which is we want the
agent to continuously learn as it
interacts with humans and so here it
thought well it's probably a good idea
to remember where the Google credentials
are stored so it called this memory tool
to create a memory of the where where
the Google credentials are stored to
save that for later this is another
example if you have that really good
context engine uh it's really critical
to getting the agent to to work
well and so now we get our output so it
prints out these logs that it searched
with an example string p programming
language and it gives some uh uh example
URLs that were returned by Google
python.org and Wikipedia.org so we have
the agent add logs to itself run itself
learn from user feedback and it used all
kinds of tools Google search codebase
retrieval file editing clarification
from the user and and memorizing uh
useful
learnings so let's fast forward and talk
through some of our lessons building
this uh I just want to know you know
we've been working on AI coding tools
for a couple years now and we didn't set
out to build agents we've worked on
things like completion models and Chad
and so forth but our Focus the whole
time was around building a super
powerful scalable Enterprise ready
context engine because we knew no matter
what no matter how good these llms get
you're going to need that context and we
also thought a lot about how do you
build great uiux so AI can seamlessly um
interoperate with humans it turns out
this context ENT and all these thoughts
around design provided a great
foundation for us to quickly build this
agent in just a couple months the three
most important things were that access
to context that context Engine with all
those different types of context sources
whether it's slack or the codebase the
reasoning capabilities from a
best-in-class uh Foundation model and
that code execution environment so you
can safely run uh commands in a uh
customer's uh
environment so let's talk through a
couple assumptions that we frequently
fall into we we have frequently fallen
into and remedied and and some of you
might encounter as
well uh so the first one is that you
know L5 agents are here the senior soft
agents are at senior software
engineering level if you look at the
Twitter demos it oftentimes can seem
like this you have an agent write an
entire website all on its
own in reality professional software
engineering is rarely zero to one and
the environments that we're coding in
are are a lot messier than what those
demos uh show you as a result these you
know aren't quite there yet but they're
still super
useful um the way one framework I've
seen people think through when they're
trying to figure out you know how to use
these agents and how to build them is
they think agents will take over entire
categories of tasks so first you build
an agent that will uh solve backend
programming and then you build an agent
focused on front- end and maybe one
focused on testing in reality this
technology is very general purpose and
so instead of thinking about categories
of tasks we found it more helpful to
Think Through levels of complexity so
our agents you know kind of good
decently good at tasks across front end
backend security and so forth and we're
we're improving the capability level
along all those fronts at once because
again it's a very general purpose
technology um we've also seen people
anthropomorphize agents so they think
they're just like human software
engineers and they map the
characteristics of a weak software
engineer to what they think a weak agent
would look like and vice versa for
strengths as well in reality agents have
different strengths and weaknesses than
humans and so you may have an agent that
can't do math but it can Implement a
whole front- end feature way faster than
any human could and it's important that
we keep this in
mind uh let's talk through a couple
Reflections and
lessons uh so here I ask aaman can you
create a stack of two PRS for the new
reasoning module using graphite
unfortunately so graphite is a Version
Control tool for working with Git you
can like stack PRS it makes it a lot
easier to review unfortunately
Foundation models have not memorized how
graphite works so our general agent
responds I don't know what graphite is
so I'll use git and then it calls our
terminal tool to run a command running
get checkout well what do we do here we
wanted it to use graphite we can't
necessarily go tell open AI or anthropic
to retrain the model understand graphite
overnight so what we came up with this
notion of a knowledge base which is
essentially a set of a s a set of
information that we want the agent to
understand that it currently doesn't we
can kind of patch holes um one thing we
wanted to add to it was this graphite
knowledge so we created this markdown
file describing graphite how to you know
run common commands things like how to
create a PR use GT create some things
not to do um we created other files in
our knowledge base for things like
details on our tool stack how to run
tests the style guide and then we add
this into the context for the agent so
it can dynamically go searching this um
knowledge base when it doesn't
understand something and uh once we
added this then you know we go ask it
can you create a stack of two PRS for
the new reasoning module using graphite
and it calls that Knowledge Graph reads
about graphi and then can run the GT
create command so what's the learning
here well onboarding the agent to your
organization is crucial the analogy I
like to think about is if you just hired
a new a new hire software engineer you
wouldn't go tell them to just stare at
the code base for 3 Days to figure out
how your Tech stack Works you'd let them
ask you questions maybe there's some
things they didn't understand and you
add some additional documents to your
notion uh we should think similarly
about
agents uh recall I was talking about how
we had all these uh thirdparty
Integrations we added whether it's
linear tools or slack tools and so forth
when we when we were working on these we
weren't really sure of which ones to
prioritize and start with on our product
road map and in a normal World we'd make
some educated guesses we'd Implement a
couple of them and go from there but
with the agents we were able to iterate
them um uh build them all at once and so
this starts to change the calculus
around how product management works uh
if you can build everything at once well
then maybe um maybe uh engineering hours
aren't the bottleneck on what we build
and it starts to uh we start to be
bottleneck a little bit more on good
product insights and good
design so when code is cheap you you can
explore more
ideas uh also recall earlier we were
talking through this example of you
instrumenting the agent Google Search
tool with logs uh and it was able to go
find the file to edit notice here how we
didn't have to give a very precise
instruction to the model we just told it
in natural language like how we talk to
another engineer to instrument the
agent's Google Search tool and I was
able to go figure out the file to edit
this only worked because we have that
really good uh codebase
awareness um we can also use the agent
for tasks outside of writing code but
still within the software development
life cycle so here we asked it to look
at the latest PRS uh in our codebase and
generated an announcement on them and
then we posted it to slack and so uh it
was titled new tools for this uh CLI
agent and we talked about some things
around slack notifications and linear uh
linear Integrations this only works
because we had that slack integration
and and understood our code base well
this uh figure may look familiar from
the beginning of the talk um we actually
had the agent make this as well so we
asked it make me a plot of the
interactive agents line of code as a
function of the
date um and so good context is critical
in all three of these tasks we needed to
pull in some different context from some
different sources and it's not just the
codebase context comes in many forms and
also note that it's multiplicative so
having access to the codebase and having
access to slack is Forex is useful as
just having access to one of
those finally I want to uh switch over
and talk about uh
testing so uh here's a really a hard to
test Edge case in our code the agent
actually wrote this um and we only
caught it because of some unexpected
runtime Behavior so we have these caches
that the agents store relevant
information for their runs in uh we can
run multiple agents in parallel and they
all write to the same cache location and
the agent wrote this save function to
save to that location and I had this
lock around the Json dump so there were
no race conditions that would explicitly
fail if you had multiple agents all
right to this cach at the same time but
notice here how there's no read before
writing to the cache and as a result you
could hit a race condition where if
multiple agents are running in parallel
they're all overriding each other's
caches and when the agent wrote this
save function why did it Miss this issue
well these agents make mistakes and this
is a hardto test situation there's some
parallel programming there's a cache
involved and so we didn't have a test
and because we didn't have a test the
agent messed up my learning here is we
need to be very careful about having
sufficient
tests um we have this pretty incredible
statistic so we have a internal bug fix
bug fixing Benchmark uh we found when we
upgraded our foundation model by about 6
months our score in this Benchmark
improved by 4% but when we added the uh
ability to run tests so the agent could
suggest a fix for the bugs run tests
look at the feedback suggest another fix
run test and do that four times that led
to a 20% gain on this
Benchmark so what's the lesson well
better tests enable more autonomy you
can trust these agents more and it just
makes them
smarter what is software engineering
look like in a world of Agents well
agents didn't work last year but now
we're pretty good if you'd ask me two
years ago if we'd be working on this
Tech I frankly wouldn't have guessed it
there's a compounding effect where these
agents are staring starting to help
build themselves and that's only going
to accelerate the pace at which they
improve code isn't going away because
it's a spec of our systems but our
relationships to it is changing good
test harnesses are becoming more
important than ever and we need to be
especially careful about those parts of
our code bases that tend to be less well
tested and the calculus of product
development is changing if code becomes
super cheap to write then the focus our
focus is more on good product work
Gathering customer feedback quickly
building
insights we're really excited for how
this Tech's going to positively
transform our industry and we'll be
releasing our agents soon so I'm really
excited to share that with you uh find
me after the talk if you want to discuss
anymore thanks
[Applause]
[Music]